so if you were somebody who was very  attractive not academic at school like  struggled with school and maybe didn't  have very much support around you  whether that's family or friends and you  saw that as a way to like yeah alleviate  your life into just getting money  quickly why don't you marry rich  EST not that easy compared to uploading  a video an eight nine or ten girl yeah  those girls if they go 20 years older  what the hell they have they'll have so  many guys lined up to do even if I could  marry a 50 year old you want a wrinkly  penis do it yeah do you want money do I  want to be on the internet naked forever  which one if I was that desperate I  would pick but at least